e
so this is
um David Nagel opening the session uh
work session on HP 54 allowing
alternative treatment centers to operate
for
profit so welcome everybody um I think
for the most part the big concerns about
this bill was not content or um what we
wanted to accomplish with it it was two
things that I heard and and
representative Woods you're happy to
chime in if I'm missing something but
one of them was I you know do we agree
or disagree on the concept of the bill
um which I don't think there was that
much disagreement on the next concern
was um um you know this is not the first
time this bill has come up it's always
hit a a wall at the governor's office is
there a way that we can look at this
bill in a man to get it you know in a
man in a form that the governor can
support um the third was
um the concern that that big cannabis
would take over
and I there there was a fourth one that
I can't remember what I was thinking
about feel free to chime in if you have
any thoughts but that's kind of where we
were and the concept was to look through
this bill and make sure that I think all
our ducks were in a row before we we
went
forward
um since I representative kofalt brought
up some very good issues and it's going
to be important that we hear what he has
to say with that said I I I did have
some concerns that I wish the folks in
the audience could address and I think I
know the answers to these questions but
I really want to hear it from you
um my big concern is
that this is a unique entity um and and
I want to make sure that the oversight
is still the same as it was before is
that accurate so it's still 126x
oversight that doesn't change at
all
problems why I mean this this is a
little problematic
because we're not the ones that had the
concerns and we wanted this work session
so that all those concerns could be
resolved and until that person's here
it's kind of hard to know what to
say yes why don't you go ahead yeah
maybe I since we're live I guess we do
need to speak into the microphone
phone were you the sponsor I am the
sponsor uh thank you I don't I don't
have my my tags on I'm sorry uh for the
record I am uh representative Wendy
Thomas representing the town of marac um
you had mentioned Governor's objections
do you know what those
are with this governor no yeah but my
understanding is that the past concerns
were you know where this would lead to I
mean you know better than me Matt you
know what the concerns were Mr chair
he's here yeah um my my take he's got
icicles from his nose sorry my my take
is that there's been uh a push from on
the state side uh to be state run and
they're looking that from the economic
perspective and they would like to run
it uh at least that's been the
perspective in years past um from what I
understand though the state run is for
adult use um and that would be up for
consideration how it's worked out I see
I see what you're saying yeah I think
that was a factor that came into play at
least uh I don't know about last session
but when I was in the house before that
was one of the concerns no it was last
session
too yeah um I am going to defer to to
the people who actually run the
dispensaries because um they will give
you more information I just wanted to
see if we we could
list the governor's possible objections
so that we can we can speak to those but
speakers just to bring you up to speed
we just started and um what we were
looking at number one is are there
concerns with this bills conceptually if
not um structurally and the concerns
that I've heard number one was um
objections potentially from the governor
that might block this um historically
that's been a problem and secondly the
other concern that I heard was the fear
that this would lead to like big
cannabis taking over and there was a
third concern that I just don't remember
what it was and I'd just be really con
you know uh Curious like what your
thoughts concerns whatever are and then
we want to hear more about the
governor and and I'm I'm not aware of
what the governor's position is on this
streaming I understand um um and
so um first of all I'd like to apologize
to everyone for being late I I ran into
uh more traffic than I expected this
morning
um so I yeah my concern is primarily the
the second one that you mentioned which
is um you know I certainly have no issue
with companies making a profit my
concern is creating an environment m in
which you have a combination of profit
motive and a high uh degree of
Regulation uh which I think is a recipe
for uh bad policy anti-competitive
practices and something that ultimately
harms consumers in this case
understanding that consumers are um sort
of a very specific um Market if I can
use that word um that are that are
trying to address uh very specific
specific health problem so I would like
to see uh I would like to see us come up
with solutions that um expand access to
care expand
availability um but that is sort of the
root of my concern is you know does this
create that kind of environment where um
people who have very very different
motives sort of swoop in and turn things
in a different direction based on
different
incentives I I I think I I totally
understand what you're saying because
mon monopolization in in healthc care is
a huge problem and if I'm understanding
you correctly that that's your concern
is that you're going to create large
entities that will crowd out the small
correct not only that they will crowd
out the smaller entities but that they
ultimately will function in a way that
does not serve the people that we're
trying to help here boy were on the same
page on stuff thanks you've just made my
statement the folks in the audience
could address the design of the bill um
how it would address that um you know um
you know there and what your thoughts
are about that because I mean it's I to
me it's a legitimate concern um Mr chair
yes um it was my understanding standing
um and disclaimer I was on the board of
tcal from the before they were actually
operational and then when I got in the
head of legislature I demur and left the
board but it was my understanding uh
that uh there no other atcs would be
allowed um in the state and as a
consequence that was that was part of
the current regulation my understanding
was that that would not change I didn't
see anything here that said this is open
in other words the the rule would still
stay that if somebody wanted to come to
the state uh there's all it would have
to be by changing legislation it would
not be just making it for profit would
not open it to everybody Tom Dick and
Harry that came across the border please
help me if I misunderstood but that was
my uh my understanding of what this
would do and not allow it to be opened
here I put you on the spot on purpose Mr
Simon Mr chairman be be before he begins
I may I sort of say in addition to what
um Dr Nagel uh requested I guess I'm
looking for comments on the sort of the
root problem because the root problem as
I heard it is has to do with financing
obtaining financing at a reasonable cost
and then um I'll just say that I I know
considerably less about medical
marijuana and atc's than the my
colleagues up here and so um I may at
times ask you to dumb it down for me a
little bit so that I can uh more clearly
understand how how things operate in the
challenges that you're facing can I just
say one more thing too because I think
we're looking at two separate issues you
raised an issue of of access in terms of
number of dispensaries but the other big
issue is how do you survive how do you
obtain
financing and to me that's what this
bill is about it's not about what you
just said and that may be a separate
issue and if I'm wrong please let me
know thank you Representatives further
record Matt Simon Granite Leaf cannabis
uh we have people behind me who are more
knowledgeable on the business aspects so
I want to let not talk a whole lot but I
wanted to address a couple of the high
level issues that came up so when this
bill first passed the political
environment was very difficult difficult
uh we had a bill in 2009 that would have
created one dispensary like a true
Monopoly the governor vetoed that bill
and we were two votes short of
overriding the veto to pass that so four
years later uh we got the current the
the current law passed allowing four ATC
licenses and the thought of having more
than four would have been politically
Unthinkable in that time because the
opposition uh was portraying everything
as you know a massive we're opening
Pandora's Box we're always opening
Pandora's box with with any cannabis
bill so there was no appetite for more
licenses than at that at the time it
wasn't a crony business lobbying thing
because there were no businesses to be
lobbying it was setting up a policy from
scratch since then uh as the program has
developed and as patients have said we
don't have enough access at first there
were only could only be four
dispensaries so a number of years ago
the legislature added the ability for
each ATC to operate a second dispensary
location so now we have a total of seven
dispensaries we can have eight by law
but there can't be more than eight and
the legislature has never had a bill
that would allow new companies to come
into this space so I've been asked that
a number of times and I've always said
that you know we wouldn't we wouldn't
oppose that that you know patients in
other states have lots of options if
you're in Maine or Vermont or
Massachusetts there are dozens of
companies if not hundreds that are
participating in a market and if one
company can't produce a product
perfectly somebody else can you just buy
it from them and everything is much more
efficient and patients have access to
the products they need as part of a
market so are we open that I think the
answer is absolutely yes but we we
haven't seen a bill on that so the
question this often gets tied up in the
debate of recreational cannabis and and
things like that I think that's
extremely unfortunate because the people
sitting behind us we have a mission it's
service to patients we don't know if
legalization is going to pass in two
years or 10 years or ever we have a law
that is set up in such a way that it
does not allow us to fulfill our mission
the way it should be fulfilled we're
we're struggling on those levels so I
want to let Keenan and Brandon behind me
talk more about how this has negatively
impacted the businesses and uh by
extension the patients by passing all of
our costs uh onto them so if I could ask
a question it seems to me that there's
two separate issues number one is we
have a finance problem that's
substantially limiting your ability to
function now but we also have a separate
access issue that's a separate issue
that we probably need to deal with
separately yeah I think so when
representative Thomas introduced the
bill she pointed out that there are five
pharmacies in in her town of marac and I
think all of us know if we get a
prescription for something we don't have
to drive 45 minutes to the pharmacy to
get it so patients will tell you that's
an issue as for the political aspects of
it I you know the governor has never
commented on this so I I have no idea
what her position might be but this bill
has passed the house with two-thirds it
has passed the Senate with two-thirds in
the past
uh if if the legislator's support for
this is overwhelming I would like to
think the governor would come to the
table actually you raised a question
that I had before so I I didn't do my
due diligence and look at every bill
that's been submitted on this subject in
the past but is this bill very similar
to the previous bills it is very similar
not identical but similar say I'm sorry
Mr it's not identical but it is similar
okay I want to make sure that Brandon
and Keenan get an opportunity so I'm
down thank you okay good
morning uh my name is Brandon Pollock I
um fairly
recently um became uh an volunteer for
the chair of the board for tascal
wellness which is one of the
atcs uh one of the three we manufacture
products in do and have dispensaries in
Lebanon
keen and um so Lebanon Keen doers are
dispensaries uh manufactur
Manchester I think essentially from our
our
perspective as um has been discussed
this is a barrier to financing and I
think practically pragmatically this
issue here is one that has faced a lot
of um States over the years most medical
marijuana programs started with
requiring their organizations to be
nonprofits uh including Massachusetts
and Maine uh as of today it's just New
Hampshire and Arizona that are left
still requiring these organizations be
nonprofits and what we've realized over
the years
is we operate as a business we run
payroll we manufacture Goods we
transport our products and we dispense
uh products to our patients in a retail
environment so we're not operating as
Charity in the conventional sense um
we're not eligible for any grant funding
we're not eligible for any uh donations
no one's supporting this uh from a
charitable
perspective um we're required to take in
revenue and pay our team and pay our
rent and operate as business however um
being structured as a nonprofit reduces
our ability in a material way to raise
funds um tascal situation right now is
it had taken out a lot of debt to get
going at very high interest rates um
very high similar to credit card
interest rates and continuing to pay
that debt is a significant burden for
the
organization if uh this legislation
makes it all the way through as it
sounds like it's gotten quite close
several times that would give the
organization flexibility to look for
more conventional business financing and
uh retire that debt load um we also in
our position where you know we've talked
with our regulator and we have support
to open an another access point as we
were just talking about we have a
dispensary that we still could open but
we can't raise the money for it right
now so that would I think be an
immediate positive benefit to something
like this is having some Financial
flexibility like any other Pharmacy
could in New Hampshire to open somewhere
else along the perhaps the Sea Coast
region where we have patients driving
all the way from you know Hampton Beach
up to do um but right now there's just
no cash flow support it
and the market for debt with interest
rates going up has actually gotten even
worse since we first did fundraising
so
um to address the concern that this
will I guess change
the perception and the visibility of
medical marijuana in New Hampshire and
create sort of big organizations first
as has been noted there's no ability for
other companies to enter the market here
it's a very small medical marijuana
Market with three companies established
by Statute at this point so that's not
realistic to have new companies come in
with a profit motive and start uh
potentially creating a different
environment and then for the existing
companies this sort of it's more of a
technical corporate change it's not
going to dramatically change the way
that we operate or our motives our
motives today are to operate as a
business we're trying to run a lean
operation we're trying to serve as many
customers as possible uh the fact of the
matter is most of our potential
customers our patients go to Maine or
Vermont right now because our prices are
so high because we have this debt we're
trying to pay off because we can't um
operate like a conventional business
so I think practically speaking allowing
us to operate as a cannabis organization
that would not have these restrictions
um without any of the benefits of a
nonprofit we're not we're not a 501c3
we're not allowed to be um recognized at
the state or the federal level for for
any tax advantages of being a nonprofit
so um I I'll pause there I feel like
I've been talking more than normal and
uh yeah happy answer any
questions so you mentioned that other
states started with the nonprofit model
and trans I to a for-profit model um I
will ask you and anybody else who wants
to comment on it later um what has been
the experience in those States following
that transition from nonprofit to
for-profit sure so um my main company is
called Theory Wellness we started in
Massachusetts now we're in six other
markets um we started as a nonprofit
under the medical marijuana program in
Massachusetts um we converted um when
the state law allowed us and our
colleagues to convert in 2019 to a uh
conventional Corporation and essentially
that allowed us to um convert our debt
that was on the books into equity which
is what our initial lenders were were
totally fine with they wanted to have an
opportunity to um realize success long
term and that allowed us to invest in
more access points and grow the
organization it also allowed a lot less
complexity on the accounting side of
trying to account as a
nonprofit when you're not actually a
nonprofit um you're have to operate as a
business so we have personal experience
it
was it's more of a corporate matter it
doesn't change any of the employees or
any of our
Sops any of our interactions with The
Regulators it's really sort of corporate
restructuring that is um lawyers do okay
on and uh we are able to just become a
little more normal that's what we've
been asking
industry thank you that's that's that's
very helpful so you also mentioned that
um there are a lot of patients that go
to neighboring states um I imagine that
there are probably also a lot of
patients who simply rely on Street
product uh which is not tested or
regulated in any way um so do you
envision that this would potentially
expand access I mean I I imagine that
this would expand access to cannabis
through the
atc's and therefore would um lower the
incidence of people sort of resorting to
buying cannabis on the street is that
yes is that accurate so I can assure you
with lower pricing which would come
through this
legislation more patience in the
material way would stay within the
program as intended uh it's simply
economic incentive if prices are higher
at dispensaries than they can buy from
their friend or from Maine a lot of
folks are going to make that decision
especially these days to not shop with
us but if we can lower pricing which we
could if we could reduce this debt load
um absolutely more patients will stay
within the program as
intended I feel like I can comment on
that from my past experience but um we
do an awful lot of counseling with
patients that get on Street product and
their answer why they do it is exactly
what you said I mean it's we're not
competitive with the marketplace and the
marketplace does include the street
vendors and I you know we constantly in
counseling say these are the risks that
you're facing they said yeah but this
all the money I got and this helps me a
lot and this is what I do and now that
we're getting you know one of my friends
works for um ni and they're looking at
um you know fenil and other way cannabis
lace with all sorts of other things and
he asked me do we have a problem with
that up here and I don't know for sure
but if we don't we will and so um you
know these are really really big Public
Safety considerations and and I just you
know the price has been a problem from
day one um I does anybody else have a
question because I have one more
but you said um I'm
sorry you said you volunteered
well the board yeah it's a volunteer
position on the board of Tasca Wellness
one of the state
atcs
yeah I don't get paid it's my I mean we
have our other organization um which is
supporting tamascal but yeah I'm
volunteering on this position y so just
following up on the question I asked
before about other states experiences
have you seen any incidents of
um this is a subjective question
question but have you seen any incid of
of you know companies with individuals
or companies with incentives that
perhaps don't align with yours
or purely profit oriented come in and
attempt to take over or or make offers
or see you know try to try to seize that
opportunity in other states yeah I mean
I my response to that is that if there's
going to be this sort of change
is really a corporate change for the
three existing organizations that are
here um in this in this bill there's no
ownership changes um allowed or
contemplated for I think at least three
years um that being said the real the
real way that a organization in a state
like New Hampshire or any other cannabis
Market sort of has to operate and how
its uh protocols run is a function of
the regulations that control um these
entities and
this legislation doesn't change any of
the overarching regulations that
underpin the medical marijuana program
in New Hampshire so we by switching from
a nonprofit to a for-profit on the
corporate back end it doesn't mean all
of a sudden we can start advertising
aggressively because we're not allowed
to do that anyway so I would suggest
that
while that's a fair it's a fair point
but right now we are operating in a way
that we're trying to maximize profit in
a techical sense where we're trying to
keep this organization afloat and um
serve as many patients as we can knowing
that most of them are still leaving the
state um while also trying to you know
reduce our utility cost by upgrading our
lighting with with LED lights which we
just did in Manchester things like that
so we're sort of already operating in in
a business sense and I don't expect
because the regulations aren't changing
I don't expect behaviors from a public
facing perspective any organization to
change I have a question um I want to
understand what this means so um if this
bill passes what it would prevent for
three years um was the sale of member
ship or shares to a foreign corporation
and I just want to understand what that
meant and I will also add in the caveat
that I I like is the two-thirds of the
members still have to be New Hampshire
residents but what exactly is a foreign
corporation uh foreign corporation a
foreign if you consider New Hampshire
domestic foreign would be an out ofate
entity
yeah I actually have one other related
question my understanding is most of the
atc's in this state now and I may be
wrong
but started as an outof State entity
that became an instate entity am I wrong
about that because like tascal I know
you came from another state but you had
to create your own inate entity correct
actually I mean the gentleman behind us
they're they're 100% independent just
New Hampshire based um tascal started in
New Hampshire and then one of the
founders actually branched out and went
into
Massachusetts uh Sanctuary same thing
they started in New Hampshire um now
they have other operations in
Massachusetts and Florida but they uh
everything was was actually started here
which is pretty interesting at one of
the first programs on the east coast
thank
you okay all right thank you gentlemen
yep
sure I I do yes I I did yeah yeah thanks
you oh Mike's already on representative
Kofa representative Nagel representative
Woods I really thank you all for taking
the time today to talk with us about HB
54 this means a lot to me personally so
I really really appreciate it um I I
come before you today um oh yeah thank
you very much um my name my name is
Keenan Blum uh I come here before you
today representing Granite Leaf cannabis
formerly known as Prime alternative
treatment centers um but I don't come
before you just as that I also have
spent nearly the last decade uh working
full-time and giving everything I have
to make sure that this program is
effective and that we serve the patients
of New Hampshire
effectively um I started as a technician
N9 years ago at the marac dispensary
um when it first opened or a little bit
before that and well I did a variety of
things there from working the counter um
doing inventory handling those things I
spent a lot of my time working
one-on-one with patients performing uh
free 1hour consultations and then
following up with them over the
preceding weeks and months to make sure
that they achieved good results with
therapeutic cannabis and if it was at
all all possible that they improved
their lives with it um it didn't help
everyone but it helped the majority of
the people we saw um and for some it was
amazing in the results they achieved and
it has driven me to continue working on
this as hard as I do um we are a company
of 45 people all of us live in New
Hampshire um and we have three
facilities a production facility out in
Peterboro and dispensaries in marac and
Chai
Chester um during that time that I
worked with patients uh most of them
early on especially most of them had
either cancer multiple sclerosis Crohn's
disease spinal stenosis or another
debilitating condition um after working
with them many of them told me that they
basically got their lives back they were
able to spend time with their family
again their grandchildren or to
participate in their Community again or
just to function to be able to get
around without as extreme of pain um so
this means a lot to me um and it's it's
really important that we continue our
mission um about four years ago I was
elected by our um by our volunteer board
as the CEO um so I've taken over that
role um and every week we encounter
obstacles to function
effectively
um I am consistently asked as we try to
improve our operations improve our
equipment find economies of scale so
that we're able to um as Brandon talked
about compete with out ofate businesses
but more so make sure that our patients
can access the medicine they need at
prices that are affordable to them and
they don't turn to other less reputable
or less caring sources for that um we we
we provide a lot more than just the
products themselves however I am
consistently asked by whether it be
equipment vendors or we we haven't
acquired financing in a very long time
um because they all ask me for a
personal guarantee I am not an owner of
this business I have no equity um I have
signed those forms because I want us to
complete our mission and fulfill what
we're supposed to do but I feel it's
onerous and it's really a challenge for
myself when you know especially when you
know we look at trying to improve
something large like um more efficient
lighting that reduces electrical and
HVAC costs when I have to sign something
saying yes we'll you know we'll owe you
these hundreds of thousands of for
equipment and I'm putting my own my own
house on the line to do so um so in in
the last four years we have worked
really hard to lower our prices um in
this in the time I've been CEO uh our
biggest category which is cannabis flow
we've reduced by 30 to 40% depending on
the skew over the last four years in the
cost that we charge patients however um
over the border for example in Maine
there are little to no regulations or
requirements and it is very very hard
for us to compete with those prices and
keep New Hampshire patients shopping in
New Hampshire keeping their money in the
economy here and allowing us to have the
income to function well to handle
everything we need to do to pay our
staff and provide good jobs so all of
that has been a huge challenge um our
patients expect better and and we want
to do better we're giving this
everything we've got but trying to run a
business that really matches a
for-profit model um that is a
manufacturer and retailer of goods and
is already extremely complex due to the
requirements of the federal government
the illegality of it at a federal level
is extremely challenging and it is only
compounded by this requirement that we
meet nonprofit requirements in New
Hampshire report to the charitable trust
unit um you know and do things in that
fashion when none of the paperwork that
I'm expected to fill out matches the I
have to explain constantly why we what
what we do with donations why do we not
have that where's our where's our
Revenue coming from and when we try to
work with vendors if I say we're a
nonprofit to try to acquire something
they say well where's your
501c3 paperwork and I say we don't have
that and they say well then who's your
owner and I say well we don't we don't
have that either so again I end up
trying to personally guarantee something
with which I have no equity um so each
one of these steps increases costs you
know uh you we with no personal
guarantee everyone expects a higher
interest rate on anything we do acquire
and currently in order to make the
improvements we're looking at improve
our laboratory improve our lighting um
renovate our dispensary or improve those
things we need a loan um and we cannot
acquire one without a personal guarantee
I have not found any that'll do it
unless you give them management control
over the entity to ensure that they get
their money back and that then even
further actually opens things up to
for-profit interests rather than a
situation where those of us that work
really hard for this have some stake and
a reason to be able to personally
guarantee items or if really needed to
acquire investors so that we can make
improvements before having to acquire
the revenue from patients to make the
Improvement we can make it first and
have patients benefit and enjoy those
economies of scale or improve improv
pieces of equipment so that is our goal
um and I you know I can continue to
explain this is the life I I live it
every day we're trying to accomplish it
but I don't want to I don't want to go
on with further detail um if you have
any questions I'd be very happy to
answer
them I was just going to say thank you
because I think everything you said has
sort of added some depth to what we've
heard before so it is very helpful thank
you representative um I do you know I I
think the experiment in New Hampshire
has been very interesting I I do
appreciate the regulation in the sense
that we get a quality product and I
think maybe it's a sad statement that
other states don't really do that um I
do think the baby steps approach to
doing this probably made sense I think
to answer your concerns there's a
statutory problem that limits the number
of dispensaries that we can have have
and that may be a separate issue that we
may want to deal with um but this is one
of the steps towards making a more
efficient model that allows us better
access and um be more competitive with
the black market as well as our laboring
states yeah I I certainly can't disagree
um thank you and we're we're a very
small company just for context we have
under 5,000 square feet of canopy where
is um a number of companies in
Massachusetts for example have a 100,000
square feet of canopy just for that
single company alone so as a a group of
45 we're really making things at very
small scale hand making things but there
are times where you know well we're hand
counting say um uh fruit shoes into
containers uh you know another company
has a counter that just puts 20 into
each bag and so these things are are
extremely challenging for us and it's
hard for us to make these Investments to
have the competitive improvements so
that New Hampshire has a program that we
can stand on and be proud of we we want
to become a company that New Hampshire
patients New Hampshire residents can be
proud of having in the state that
represent us well but it is really hard
to do it when with our hands somewhat
tied in in certain areas and well we
want the we love the mission and the
idea behind the nonprofit intent the
actual practical application of it is
extremely challenging
so I also wanted to point out one thing
that you said very early in your early
experience that's very unique to New
Hampshire that's really important that
does have a
cost um the medical expertise on
cannabis certification oversight is
extremely limited uh I think a lot of
the docs that certify not and including
me don't have the knowledge base that we
really need and we really rely on what
you guys do with your patient
education um which is really important
and I'm not sure every other state does
that not to the level that you guys do
it and that's that's got a cost too that
that we really should be proud that we
do that um because on some states you
just walk and grab some stuff and leave
I mean you don't do it that way and
that's really needs to be pointed out it
is and that's an extremely frustrating
thing for us because when the cost is
compared the cost is compared by you
know a a a a unit of of of in edible or
an amount of flour and the reality is is
that's not the entirety of the services
we provide even today we employ a
full-time educator on staff out of our
40 time 45 people we have a full-time
and a part-time um and we offer still
hourlong consultations for free for any
patient that wants it whether they shop
with us or not and we will continue to
do that regardless we've found that I've
I've just seen it make improvements to
people's lives and the idea of passing
that on that opportunity is something I
would never want to do um however we
want to have patients come through our
doors to offer them that service rather
than than thinking I'll I'll save some
money move my move my funds out of state
but acquire cheaper cannabis and the
long-term detriment that they're less
likely to find what really helps them
with their symptoms and conditions a lot
of what we recommend isn't a higher dose
or more sales or them consuming more
it's very specifically targeting the
particular thing they might need which
surprisingly often is say non-
intoxicating thca is an
anti-inflammatory not something that you
know reduces their you know immediate
mental capacity to function or something
else it's something that allows them to
effectively goe um just as uh you or
perhaps anybody else reviews this do you
see any sort of you know loopholes um
that would
allow some big Corporation to to move in
uh and be um a
player or is this protective of the
current
status I I don't necessarily see any
loopholes um I think at the moment the
the and for the foreseeable future this
program in a small state is small enough
that there isn't a huge amount of
incentive or much incentive for a large
Corporation to be involved in that type
of situation there certainly is a little
bit of Revenue to be had and potentially
you know profit so to speak but we're
not talking anything hugely substantial
we have 15,000 total customers available
us to in the to us in the state at this
time so when you kind of think about
what a individual might spend we're not
we're not talking hundreds of millions
of dollars here so you don't in terms of
the law itself you don't see any
loopholes that uh yeah that's the main
main concern no but I I I don't think I
do um but I do appreciate your viewpoint
on it and that's certainly a a
perspective that I I think I appreciate
you taking and that we're happy to
collaborate on is just making sure that
this doesn't have any loopholes or a
situation that brings us to a bad place
um I don't want to have cannabis in New
Hampshire become a profit making machine
that takes it advantage of New Hampshire
patients I think that would be the worst
result or one of the worst results we
could possibly have so I think guard
rails that Ure that doesn't happen are
completely reasonable um however I I
don't think that that the solution there
is to require nonprofit status in New
Hampshire when it's not available
federally those there's no benefit to
that that makes it harder but I I do
very much respect and and you know
appreciate the intention that you have
of that question and the goal that's
there I think that's something that it's
extremely important that we maintain and
I don't know if I can offer a solution
at this moment but you know I think it's
something we should work on I mean I
think there is an answer to that I mean
126 X7 still uh overseas who can buy in
this state so there's still a lot of
State oversight am I correct I'm looking
at you because you know the law you guys
know the law really he's looking behind
you yeah I mean my understand
understanding is that that none of that
goes away there's still a lot oversight
as to who can buy in the state that
doesn't change
so um that would limit what you're
that's it seems to me the guard rail is
already in place and I think the foreign
corporation guardrail is probably the
the largest there's a period of time and
expectation and and limitations to when
and and who it could be sold for I think
keeping making sure that any essentially
profits or benefits that are provided
from this program program go to the
patients of New Hampshire or to those
doing the work and who live in New
Hampshire and are contributing to our
economy and keeping things going in that
regard I think as long as we are
accomplishing those goals then this
would be a really positive bill for the
people of New Hampshire and certainly
thanks that's it thank you thank you so
much so we only have minutes left um I'm
I'm not sure Our obligation is to make
some sort of a
recommendation um we have an option of
either doing that now or doing it
another day well I wonder if you want to
ask if there's anybody else here who
would like to U say anything yes go
ahead
sorry do we have a time
limit
suppos all right ignore what I just said
about time hi there oh this works good
um my name's Nathaniel gri and I live in
Sandwich New Hampshire um and um I just
thought I'd give you um a um to speak to
you as a um certified um can uh medical
cannabis patient and my own experience
um when I first um was certified as a
patient several years ago I was very
happy to um visit um one of the
sanctuary atcs this one was in Conway um
Conway and Plymouth both Sanctuary atcs
are about equidistant for me but I tend
to shop a little bit more in the Conway
area um and I visited them and they were
very helpful um in um recommending um
the right products for me um and I made
my purchase um and that is other than
stopping in to say hello it was the last
time I actually went there because um
literally 5 miles away across the border
in fryberg um they have medical cannabis
dispensaries five of them actually and
the one that's actually closest to
Conway um basically sells pretty much
the same product for half the price um
and I have to tell you that I'm um a
very great supporter of the um um ATC
and therapeutic cannabis program in New
Hampshire and I really really really
would like to support um my local
dispensaries um and and frankly even if
the dispensary was 20% more expensive I
would support them but um you know 100%
more expensive um is uh is just not
economical for me um and that has been
my experience and um you know I think
that that's unfortunate and I think that
um that this uh particular bill would go
a long way to um helping the atcs be
more
competitive again that's that's very
helpful I've written down the the
pricing information you gave me because
I think that that plays into this in a
very important way so thank thank you
yeah that was really important thanks
I'm sorry I almost neglected you any a
sure uh again for the record Wendy
Thomas from the town of marac I have
heard very clearly that there is an
appetite a possible appetite for opening
up more dispensaries just letting you
know that I'm going to look into to that
and get on that I get on top of that but
it would depend and it would rely on
this bill passing thank
you that was really important you said
that because of the experience with
tascal not being able to open up a new
facility because they can't Finance it
and that's a big problem exactly and and
um Matt referenced it but but when I
testify I always say five pharmacies in
my town if I need pain relief I'm not
more than 10 minutes away from it you
know and there's some people in the
state that have to travel over an hour
to get to their their dispensaries to
get their medicine and this is medicine
we're not talking excuse me we're not
you can say who you
are uh for the record my name is Michael
Holt I'm the administrator of the
therapeutic cannabis program with the
Department of Health and Human Services
Department doesn't have a position on
the bill um I don't have any you know uh
proactive statements but I uh do want to
be a resource to the subcommittee if
that is possible I'm just going to ask
oh go ahead you go I'm going to ask you
the same same question uh the bill that
stands do you see any change uh any
difficulties any loopholes in terms of
making this still a secure uh Endeavor
in the
state the bill doesn't change any of the
I just state regulations or the state's
authority to regulate these entities
heard we've not heard any specific
concerns from this government or or this
Governor or this this committee um it's
hard to it's hard to assure that there
are new loopholes when I don't know what
the loophole is that we're concerned
about um you know we can go back to
looking at the the governor's passed
vetos um I just looked up the the most
recent one of the recent ones from 201
21 and his concern was that it would
unfairly position these three companies
if and when legalization would happen um
it would guarantee them these three
companies a a monopoly on the
legalization services I don't know if
that's I don't see that as being
necessarily true as we've seen you know
legislation in the past has uh has
restricted atc's access to the
legalization Market but as far as just
addressing what this bill does I just
want to clarify and assume the answer
would be no there is no loopholes in
terms of security
true um I I can offer you
know a full quarter of uh so there's
15,000 patients in the program um a full
quarter of them have never been to a
dispensary in uh last year in uh in 24
um on a quarterly basis less than half
go to a
dispensary um so when we hear when we
hear talk about the revenue coming in
from those 15,000 patients it's it is a
it is a small subset of uh of those
patients and again most of them are
going to Maine um we know that they tell
us that they tell the program that every
day because it's uh it's far cheaper
what they don't know is that the medical
marijuana in Maine is not regulated so
so there's no requirements for testing
pesticide control Etc um that's a real
problem in terms of uh quality and
safety uh inhaling heavy metals Etc
there's no regulation of uh the the
so if I may I so I I think the um you
know we're we're kind of winding down to
the end of our time here um I don't
think we're required to come back with a
recommendation um I will offer my
opinion and if if uh the rest of the
subcommittee wants to uh tends to agree
with me then then I think we can come
back with a recommendation
um although though I remain wary of this
combination of high regulation plus
profit motive I think that there are it
some of what I've learned is a that
there there are U pretty strong
guardrails in place and B uh
that short of sort of a sort of creeping
changes to those there's really not room
for uh big cannabis to swoop in and um
sort of
uh bastardize the the the the market and
the the services that are being provided
um at the same time I'm hearing
potential safety issues with people
buying Street marijuana um price is too
high access is limited expansion of atcs
is limited um you know I have heard
outside of this that the survival of
atcs may be at risk um so I guess you
know what I'm coming with way with is
that the um my potential I think that
the the the actual real world problems
um are significantly larger than uh my
concerns although I still have some
concerns um I guess my my uh Instinct at
bill I I would do the same I my my take
is that the guard rails are clearly
intact um uh and it's what we're hearing
the quality which is really what we want
we're taking care of patients uh and uh
the quality remains and we've heard the
difference between Maine and here and
that's I'm sad to hear there's that much
difference but I guess that's the way it
is uh but with the guard rails in place
uh some of the issues that you raised
you know the availability uh and
competing with the street uh uh folks
that may be subjected to fenel uh that
may be addressed if they have the
ability uh with this bill to change
their financing and I have seen that and
I'll offer as I again I was on to
Schools board before I got a legislature
and saw this firsthand and the
constraints that it does u u impose so I
I think it would answer some not all but
it would go a part way and I think it's
the kind of Step it's a graduated step
it's a protected step uh and it's aimed
in the right direction and I I think it
would be um uh we would be remiss not to
take the step uh given the fact that it
is protected in in that way um but uh I
will just offer another comment I I do
have some
concerns uh it is still uh categorized
as a illegal drug there are motions in
place
uh the doj has been held in abeyance
basically by presidential
order um that could
change uh and that would be a absolute
unmitigated
disaster um so uh I I'm not trying to be
a dark cloud but I do have some
concerns um with the current meu uh
drugs being such a high-profile item in
political discussions that this could
trickle
down especially with the complete uh uh
a redo of
nervous I'll make a move to pass I will
oh sorry do we need a roll call no all
in favor I think we are uh we were in
agreement thank you this was really
wonderful I'm glad we did this thank you
very
much yeah thank you everybody for making
the trip here uh it it has been helpful
I have learned a lot from the past hour
you